i'm going to give you three pictures and
you tell me which one this one
this one or this one give me the
the let's go with the let's go with the
elliott page wannabe
well uh dissociated uh the one who lies
about in my opinion
lies about having multiple personality
disorder
uh she's back she was off for a little
while she's back and i think this is one
of her male alts
yeah well you can tell because she's
wearing a hat and a leather jacket
that's basically what female to males do
they just throw on a ball cap and
they're like what's up bro
look okay she's still a woman yeah she
said you know what you know what uh
female-to-male should do you guys should
buy
you guys should buy fake mustaches now i
like that i'll dope would that be if
they all had fake taped on mustaches
so yeah this is um this is uh one of her
alters for those that don't know we've
covered uh dissociate did
whatever before and she's one that i
think she has like 67 different
personalities
i think the term is being a liar and
growing up
so uh this is her talking about coming
back and this is a family friend's
dating what
what are we uh dissociative identity
disorders what they call it now it's not
multiple personality anymore it's called
dissociative
dissociative identity disorder
all right guys what's up this is kyle
and this is another video from oh this
she's kyle now and this is her kyle
persona
after a meme yeah this is kyle so
i don't get it right like you're you're
making up a fake
thing you couldn't make up a cooler name
it's brad you don't need brad well she
has a bunch of names remember that
this is kyle is surprised is a male
primary protector
right i'm just so she did today's video
was voted for and suggested by
our patreon so if you are interested
patrons you mean with that music playing
over it this sounds like those like old
like
um you know that grime wrap that that uk
grime wrap
which one of our alts really likes red
wine too much look at those teeth
that's red wine stains in helping us
shape the channel deciding what videos
we make
she's also british though yeah it's true
big book of british smiles a big book of
british smiles is one of the funniest
bits on that show ever
have a look at our patreon and you'll be
able to help pick videos like this one
so what our patients voted for this time
around was autodynamics
so so we've heard all our different
voices i guess kyle has more of a
cockney accent
i guess a little more cockney but like
if he's your primary protector right
like what's the difference other than
he's a guy because
he's still in your body right so he's
like not a protector he's still a guy
whose bones i could shatter with my bare
hands exactly
your little bird bones i would murder
kyle like i would
murder him how always interact within
the system and that's the thing can i
hit you
when you're kyle it's a guy yeah why not
the relationships there are what it's
like to
live with people in your head all the
time basically
[Music]
i'm so sick of these stingers i'm sick
of youtuber
stingers they're the worst they're
always terrible
i thought i was probably the best one to
do this video because i'm primary
protector
which basically means that i have the
most insight
but wait a minute so you just plan on
what like so she could control it
apparently
that's not how anything like that works
uh
excuse me anything like that real
you don't just go like hey i gotta have
i gotta make sure my other personality
kyle is here today at three o'clock i
got a show to do
like and then kyle just appears like
that seems a little
i don't know fake and made up and gay
damn i know what goes on i know who's
around i know
generally how people are getting on
where people are at you know
i've got the down low on most things
because that's my job right
so like every system is good
i'm sorry i just had nin in the back of
my head saying yeah take a drink
every time kyle is like no don't do that
take a drink of water so now
her two pers one of her other
personalities is talking to her in the
back of her head
she's allowed to be in society and drive
a car
um i'm sorry but uh hello everybody
to quote the great joey gibson at least
pronounce it right it's society
yes stay hydrated somebody else some new
people here don't know about this
we haven't done this about a year how
big is her audience uh 1.7
1.7 million subscribers yeah yeah things
are going to be different
for every system so it doesn't matter
whether you've got a deal
mike look i know you don't like kyle
okay i don't like kyle either this dude
bugs me
so why don't we bring in uh another one
this is one of her female lots talking
about dating
what's this dumb name i this this one
has a few different women in it so
um get ready for the accent change
everybody
welcome back to another video by
dissociated my name is sally and i'll be
the one presenting this video to you
today
it's this is sally it was sally's turn
today so you sit there
and you sally yourself up yeah
and you put all these uh all this makeup
and [ __ ] on right and then what you
you look what happens if kyle shows up
does kyle call himself yeah i'm not
putting on this
[ __ ] bro yeah how does this work your
turn kyle how does this work
i need i need sally back it's weird how
like
even though she says to switch caught on
camera even though she says that she
can't control her switches
that she always has her makeup ready
and her clothing perfect for switches
and that's like so if i'm [ __ ] this
and she turns into kyle
congratulations you could join the
military it's not fair man
this video is about dating people with
the id or ostd
and it will yeah look all men date women
they're all liars we all know how to
deal with it it's just a different kind
of lying
work for you regardless of whether you
have a singular integrated personality
whether you are a system yourself so
which one do you have an
integrated personality or do you have a
system no i don't i have [ __ ] to do lady
that's what i have it's natural and
ethical products
that have a high variety of different
options so that they can be swapped out
depending on who's taking care of the
body that morning
we've been using native deodorant she's
doing a live read
yeah of course which wait wait wait so
this personality
is okay with is there a personality
that's against corporations and live
reads
uh no they're all greedy pigs okay we
tend to gravitate towards
natural and ethical products i'd like to
tell you about better health
it's not working for her yeah a high
variety of different options so that
they can be swapped out depending on
who's taking care of the body that
morning
we've been using native deodorants for
seven months now since july 2020 i
believe
and that's the longest we've ever stuck
with one brand
they're paying you formula at least
we're honest with our live roots and
they go hey look they're paying us so
we're gonna read this
we really do try with that stuff to be
honest with you guys it's paraben free
sulfate free and
aluminium free and it's so smooth and
moisturizing
native are also vegan and cruelty free
which supports the ethics of most okay
i'm skipping ahead from the library if
you don't mind
countries too deodorant to about have to
even think about if you were dating
somebody with a singular personality
that doesn't mean that it's any less
important to know one of the first
things that you should do is make sure
that you understand did or osdd
and any other illnesses that your
partner may have by being informed and
educated yeah which which one which one
of her alts has hpv
one of them has to right it just goes
away when the
personality goes correct yeah now how to
support them best what their disorder
means for them and how it changes their
life
would greatly support you and help you
through your relationship with them
alters other own individuals it's a
really good point bust the nut bar says
does this company decide which one of
our alts does the live read like yeah
do they get to pick yeah uh can it be
one of the pretty ones please
and they are just as much a real person
as you are hey guys
kyle here for dollar shave club
when i'm shaving my man [ __ ] and my man
[ __ ]
and my armpits
you just picture this chick has dollar
shave club razors
piling up in a corner in her [ __ ]
room she just doesn't use them
all individuals and they will all have
their own preferences and their own
boundaries
that means that you need to learn as
many of them as you can respect each
alter because they are their own person
and everybody deserves respect even if
you're not dating them
one of the first things so like if i
have an altar that's because this is a
great grift honestly
if i have an altar that's a black guy do
i get an n-word pass
no it would be dumb how does it work
because i want to know how this works
yeah because it worked for um
[Music]
it worked for um what do you call it i i
can't even think of it now but um
the tourette's girl she got away oh yeah
yeah yeah controversy
yeah to figure out when you're dating
somebody who has more than one
personality
is who are you dating are you dating at
all
is this a strictly sexual relationship
is it a romantic relationship or is it
something different
and who is involved just because you're
dating one alter
even if that's the host the alter who's
out most often
that doesn't mean that you're
necessarily in a relationship with that
system
or with anybody else in that system so
so does every alt get to have a
different like
partner i guess no because like
this cut like let's say kyle likes like
kyle gets the [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] susie over here gets
gets the [ __ ] dudes
i mean that's i i don't know i'm asking
cuz i really don't know it's also very
confusing
i think we're gonna catch a switch here
means that you should pay attention to
what their triggers are and maybe have a
conversation about them if you're
comfortable
are there any particular topics or
situations that are triggering for you
that i should know about
i can make sure to avoid them in the
future and share information between
alters unless you have explicit
permission to do so
what so you can't like
like this she can't share information
that kyle thinks to like if she's dating
somebody oh
that would be really [ __ ] up it's an
easy way to lie about things
it really does seem like a very good
it's almost like a hall pass to just do
shitty things and then be like
oh that was kyle kyle did that we all
hate kyle
i didn't cheat on you all right sally
cheated on you
sally sucked that guy's dick do you
okay do you want to see her switching
personalities yeah i love how she does
this on camera
if you have any questions please leave
them for us and i'm sure that
nin will be able to make a video when
anything else that you want to be
discussed
ah i'm dissociating
you know what can i can i ask an honest
question this one might sting a little
bit ladies
particularly white women
why is it that all of you and i do mean
all of you
why do all of you women
have this need to be anything but
yourself
why is that right it's like because they
don't they don't like that i can answer
that for you they don't like themselves
man
why do you you need to be anything but
what you just
are yeah i've never seen a group of
people on the planet more uncomfortable
with the idea of just being what they
are
and they they either become like this or
they put pant suits on and they go i'm
going to go make it in corporate world
and it's like could you just be what you
are
stop trying to [ __ ] prove yourself to
everybody
so that i want to see her because she
does she's a terrible actress by the way
look at her disassociating here we go
ah i'm disassociating
that's the face i make when i'm farting
in public and i don't want nobody to
know
what's that no i'm fine i'm fine oh what
is that
there's a face you make when you're
peeing in a public pool you want to act
normal
and you're like why is that you know
what the funny thing about peeing in a
pool is is that you
like the trick is to try to like still
move around like you're being normal
of course but it's really hard to do
most people will just stand and pee and
that's how you can spot the peers the
one that's just standing there you go
i guess being
somebody did point out that they think
that all of her personalities take anal
which
is a you know plus i mean kyle would
have to
here we go she's dissociating here she
goes
if this woman didn't ever made up
disease she knows deep down she'd be so
uninteresting
oh i know of course
what's up kyle why am i dressed like
yo did we do the live read already yeah
hey why am i dressed like a [ __ ]
broad dude why do i look like a [ __ ]
[Music]
broad
somebody said they don't do this here's
the thing though right with the they
there is no they these people don't
exist multiple personalities
don't exist people that do that don't
exist
they're all liars they're all it's it's
like
thank you yeah like a clairvoyant it's
like a psychic
like there's a bunch of [ __ ]
historical references to psychics and
you know this guy was psychic and all
this [ __ ] like but they're just liars
there's just people that have had this
lie for hundreds of years i have
multiple personalities it's like roy
said it's just a really good way to
lie or get away with [ __ ] yeah and the
the thing is like is
they they'll every time whenever we clip
this stuff and we put it up there
they'll be like
oh there was they always put out there
was just one doctor one time that said
it was real
but then when you really look into it
the consensus of most doctors
is that there's no scientific way to
prove that this is real there's no way
to prove that it's real
so this is like i could right now if
we're gonna
we're gonna go by this if i wanted to i
could just say
just by watching her videos i could say
that i have this disorder i have my
dissociative
identity oh my god that's horrible dude
are you i do it's crazy oh hold on i'm
disassociated right now
what up dawg [ __ ] dog what's going on
man what's up dude what's your name dog
uh my my my name's tyrone dawg like
afros
i'm from cincinnati that's what's up you
got some weed on you tyrone
[ __ ] you know i do what you need dog i'm
not gonna lie i already like tyrone
between you and me you're way cooler
than royce yeah i mean i don't even want
that royce guy to come back
all right um it's kind of mean wait i
thought you were
i'm disassociated
[Laughter]
uh can you get tyrone back because that
guy was really cool
no i can't hold on tyrone's telling me
something he said he went to go
get cigarettes he'll be right back so
we'll see if tyrone shows up
the way royce has several personalities
too he also has a
personality his name is rice hey stop
don't tell people what's your what's the
name what's the name of your
personality royce i guess the same guy
[ __ ] the same dude oh [ __ ]
it's just you just zone out like she
does for like two minutes and then start
blinking and then you come back and
you're like
same voice go suck your dick and you're
like wait a minute is that even a new
personality
no i just nod it off for a second i was
tired you know what kind of dick
tyrone's telling me something right now
he wants to know if he could hold your
phone for me yeah
yo can i yo can i hold your phone for a
second just for a minute yo
or do you got the chargers i could
charge mine
i could charge mines on your on your
charger
i'll tell you what could i i don't even
need your phone but can you give me a
wi-fi password
so i can check my facebook on my phone
it's like yeah man like i ain't pay my
phone bill or whatever but if you let me
use your wi-fi
i could let my wee guy know through
facebook messenger
that i need to meet up with him wait
he's saying something
he said if you're going to the store can
you get some backwoods
he says you'll know what that means can
you get me some backwoods
and some [ __ ] crab chips please thank
you
he wants to store brand spicy cheetos
hey man yeah can you give me some hot
cheetos
and uh one of them [ __ ] uh uh
what they got there one of them purple
bug juices two one
a quarter so that's all we got it
all right look so i'm i i want to say
that i also have this disorder so i've
ever seen anything
uncool for anything that's that you
would find to be breaking terms of
service it's one of my alts yo while
you're there can you do me a favor you
buy me two new ports
you're like two packs of newport or just
like nine two six no you gotta go to the
other store on hillsboro
they got lucy's okay perfect
that's when you know you're in a good
neighborhood when they sell lucy's which
by the way is so highly illegal
you're not allowed to do that but did
that dude get killed in new york for it
no not on the streets i mean in stores
oh yeah of course these guys you just go
like i've been in so many ghetto like
when i was trying to quit smoking
and it's really hard to quit smoking
when you live at a place that has lucy's
because then it's like all right you
could just go in there and be like
let me get one cigarette and guess what
there's only one kind of cigarette they
swear to god you can't find
regular cigarettes that are lucy's you
can't like if you go in and go
you got a non-menthol lucy they'll be
like no only newport
um i'm sorry mike i'm disassociating
again really quick
oh god
what are you i'm a cruise ship director
oh
what are you rich foss yeah i just
disassociated it's great any [ __ ] up
in here
this is actually the straightest version
of royce this is
the the straightest version of roy
straight as he gets guys
toot all right i think we're done with
this video i didn't know i didn't know
one of royce's personalities was
one of the stars of fat love boat
[Laughter]
or just love but it was filmed today
it's true
um american love boat yeah american love
boat
this is love boat but it takes place on
a carnival cruise
it's like love boat except we can only
let half the amount of passengers
on legally now all right
we're done uh but so whatever she has a
fake disease i guess is the whole point
of all this